le décollage était parfait la suite
s'est déroulée rondement ce matin en
californie la compagnie spacek ce encore
elle a mis en orbite sans problème les
trois nouveaux radars sat canadien
l'agent spatiale canadienne à deux misé
gros
à lui seul le delta 9 transportait 1,2
milliard de dollars d'équipements et 15
ans d'efforts réalisés par des centaines
d'employés
c'est un grand moment pour le canada
c'est un grand moment pour le programme
spatial
le trio de satellite viendra bientôt
prendre la relève de radars stade 2
lancé en 2008 mais cette nouvelle
génération est plus raffiné plus
efficace et va travailler en équipe
si ce qu'on répartisse il a la charge
sur les trois systèmes et ça nous offre
davantage de faire une couverture
quotidienne du canada
on ne peut pas faire jusqu'à
présentement équipés d'une panoplie
d'instruments sophistiqués des radars
sat vont prendre deux cent cinquante
mille photos par année soit 50 fois plus
que la première génération
ils peuvent tous faire l'équivalent d'un
couteau suisse suivre la progression des
bateaux mesurer l'épaisseur des glaces
l'érosion du sol
les niveaux d'eau et même estimer le
niveau d'humidité des sols en termes
d'agriculture ça permet de détecter les
types de cultures
la croissance des cultures on veut
prévoir le rendement qui culture en vont
donc on peut savoir si le char est
productif ou quoi où comment intervenez
pour améliorer la productivité et
satellites vont être particulièrement
utile en cas de catastrophe
environnementale pour épauler les
équipes d'intervention sur le terrain
mais c'est très sensible à cette
question là aux associations
qui ont terme à la surveillance maritime
surveillance des écosystèmes la capacité
de temps des images à travers les nuages
peu importe les conditions
météorologiques peu importe
l'élimination solaire il faudra attendre
au moins trois mois avant que les radars
ça tu soit pleinement opérationnel on
estime qu'ils auront une durée de vie
utile d'au moins 7 ans ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal